je dirais le plus facile pour nuire à
quelqu'un c'est quand même d'inventer
des affaires de mœurs s'imaginaire et
notamment sur des enfants et si possible
entre bas âge comme ça naturellement les
éléments de preuve qui peuvent être
apportées à charger à des charges sont
beaucoup plus complexes à apporter donc
ça reste ce qu'il y a à la fois le plus
infamant le plus destructeur ou les
dommages collatéraux directs et
collatéraux sont les plus importants et
où il sera également le plus difficile
de s'en débarrasser pour la personne qui
est innocente
accusé à tort
plus qu'une simple qualification
une chaîne
un boulet contraine lorsque la machine
judiciaire s'abat sur nous
comment prouver son innocence face à
l'innommable
comment supporter le regard des autres
comment ne pas se laisser broyer par la
justice
Christophe et Patrick ont dû s'opposer
souvent ces questions tous deux ont été
accusés à tort
leur histoire me touche j'ai envie d'en
savoir plus
comment ont-ils vécu ce jour où sans
raison ils se sont retrouvés sur le banc
des accusés
je suis Christian Boudou 46 ans j'étais
en 2001 accusé à tort je m'appelle
Patrick le bonheur je j'ai 39 ans et
j'ai été accusé à tort
[Musique]
Christophe Patrick
deux hommes dont la vie a basculé un
jour à cause d'accusation infondée
depuis il ne cesse de se battre pour
faire reconnaître leur innocence un
combat qui dure depuis des années
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Christophe se rend un
sarcelle à 20 km au nord de Paris
on va voir mon petit garçon de 11 ans
victorien et c'est vrai que je suis
toujours super content de voir
victorien vit chez sa mère cela fait 10
ans que ses parents sont séparés pour
Christophe Bridoux ces moments-là sont
très importants
que tu m'as mis que tu m'as donné le
parfum rouge là il y a encore quelques
années Christophe était privé de son
droit de visite
si Christophe n'a pas pu voir victorien
avant l'âge de 7 ans c'est qu'il a été
accusé de fait très grave
nous sommes en 2001 à l'époque
Christophe Bridoux commande la police
municipale de Garges-lès-Gonesse
divorcée et père de 3 enfants il s'est
remarié avec Véronique et vient d'avoir
son 4e enfant victorien
mais cette vie bien rangée s'effondre un
jour symbolique le 11 septembre 2001
tout commence ici à la mairie
[Musique]
j'arrive dans mon service
je revais ma tenue de police comme tous
les jours je suis dans mon bureau je
suis seul isolé le téléphone sonne je
décroche et là au bout du fil j'ai ma
supérieure hiérarchique elle me demande
de me présenter dans les plus brefs
délais dans son bureau à l'époque
de Garges-lès-Gonesse il se rend
aussitôt à cette convocation et selon
ses dires avant de le faire entrer dans
son bureau madame le Maire lui aurait
posé une question surprenante au sujet
de sa vie privée
non je tombais un petit peu des NU
considérant que je m'attendais pas à
cette question très loin de là je ne
réponds pas directement à sa question
elle Ritter une seconde fois cette
question et je réponds affirmative et là
je vois un grand sourire émerveillé et
me faire entrer dans le bureau une fois
entrée Christophe dit être surpris par
le comité d'accueil face à lui des élus
et des responsables administratifs qui
l'accusent brutalement on m'accuse
d'avoir volé des heures supplémentaires
escroquer des communications de
téléphonique et on me dit que j'ai volé
un téléviseur
le chef de la police municipale conteste
ses accusations mais personne ne le
croit
on me suspend avec un arrêté municipal
quasiment sur le champ Christophe est
perdu il ne comprend pas sans la moindre
preuve c'est supérieur lui inflige une
lourde sanction une suspension d'office
je me dis très clairement ils sont en
train de combattre une erreur ils vont
ils vont s'apercevoir de leur erreur
d'ici quelques temps avant de rentrer
chez lui Christophe est raccompagné à
son bureau par un élu il lui demande de
rendre sa carte de police et son
uniforme un moment humiliant j'avais
l'impression d'être de revoir un peu
l'affaire Dreyfus
lorsque son supérieur le cas ce sabre ou
lui retire c'est ses épaulettes mais
j'étais exactement dans la même
condition comme si je reçois une cascade
d'eau froide sur la tête tout le corps
pour moi je comprends pas
[Musique]
Jean-Marc Florent vous êtes avocat vous
avez fait acquitter de nombreux
accusateurs dont le plus célèbre Patrick
Dils dans cette histoire Christophe
Bridoux n'est pas encore confronté à la
justice et pourtant sa situation soulève
déjà une question pour ce type
d'accusation peut-on suspendre un
employé même sans preuve effectivement
il est possible notamment pour les
salariés qui arrivent droit du travail
si on estime que la personne a commis
une faute qui perd des conséquences
pénales mais une tout court même si elle
n'a pas encore eu des conséquences
pénales de le suspendre par une mise à
pied conservatoire dans l'attente de son
licenciement mais là ce qui paraît assez
frappant dans ce cas c'est qu'il y a eu
une précipitation quand même coupable
pour se défaire de ce monsieur dans le
cadre de son emploi alors que
visiblement il y avait aucun élément de
preuve tangible à son encontre donc je
crois quand même ce que ce qu'il faut
rappeler c'est qu'il y a un principe de
précaution et un principe de
proportionnalité également en fonction
et qu'on ne peut pas prendre une
sanction y compris en droit du travail
ou administrative selon les régimes sans
avoir quand même des éléments de preuve
et des éléments de preuves précis et
circonstanciés alors la visiblement
c'était pas le cas du tout et en tant
qu'employé est-ce qu'on a des recours
d'autant que là en plus il y a sa
réputation qui est en jeu alors en tant
qu'employé sinon dépend du Code du
travail on dépend du conseil des
prud'hommes on peut la différence c'est
des prud'hommes pour contester le
licenciement pressé pour faute grave
lourdes à qualifier et précéder une mise
à pied conservatoire si on le peut c'est
très long comme démarche
sont déjà réalisés puisque vous êtes
déjà mis à pied vous ne pouvez plus
aller sur votre lieu de travail d'y voir
ni rencontrer vos collègues ni accéder à
votre bureau généralement et à vos
documents à vos papiers votre ordinateur
après vous êtes licencié et après vous
allez au Conseil prud'hommes et tout le
monde sait qu'il y en a pour des mois
voire des années naturellement les
dégâts sont déjà acquis pour le salarié
s'il est accusé à toi
dans les semaines qui suivent cette mise
à pied Christophe Bridoux passe ses
journées chez lui prostrée sa femme
Véronique qui n'est pas au courant de la
situation ne comprend pas elle décide
d'appeler la mairie alors au téléphone
une femme
qui lui annoncera non seulement que je
suis suspendu mais qu'en plus je suis
attiré par les hommes donc je suis
homosexuel la femme de
Christelle la double vie de son
mari dans les semaines qui suivent elle
demande le divorce un coup dur pour
Christophe sans famille sans travail
accusé de fait qu'il conteste ils
sombres dans la dépression
c'était pour moi quelque chose de
d'insuptable navigable j'en peux plus je
craque je craque complètement
je prends j'achète une bouteille de une
bouteille d'alcool fort assez fort
et j'avais sur moi deux tubes de
tranquillisant extrêmement fort et je
les absorbe d'un coup Christophe Brid
oux un proche le retrouve
et vient les secours il sera sauvé mais
il n'est pas tiré d'affaire pour autant
il va bientôt être accusé de quelque
chose de beaucoup plus grave
[Musique]
comme chaque jour Patrick Leveneur prend
son service de chauffeur de bus
bonjour
pour les passagers du bus 64 bonjour
Patrick est un chauffeur anonyme que
l'on salue à la va-vite les voyageurs
sont loin très loin d'imaginer les
épreuves qu'il a traversé car un jour
cet homme a été accusé à tort
retour au printemps 1997 à l'époque
Patrick est marié avec Michel depuis 5
ans ils ont deux fils et attendent leur
troisième enfant mais leur vie va
basculer le jour où il reçoit un
courrier d'un commissariat situé à 800
km de là à Marseille
ça c'est la convocation que j'ai reçue
pour me rendre au commissariat avec mon
épouse le 11 mars 1997
à 14h30 notre billet pour l'enfer sans
savoir pourquoi ils sont convoqués le
couple prend le train pour Marseille
ils y ont vécu quelques années
auparavant pour eux ce ne sera qu'une
simple formalité administrative mais dès
qu'il se présente au commissariat
Patrick et Michel sont placés en garde à
vue et les faits dont on les accuse sont
très graves
on me dit vous êtes accusé de viol de
quoi qui c'est qui m'accuse de l'avoir
violé votre belle-sœur Laetitia ah bon
quand elle me dit ouais ça s'est passé
en 89 90 91 à plusieurs reprises ah bon
et avec la complicité de votre épouse
et donc voilà donc vous tombez des nues
quoi vous déjà vous prenez un moment de
recul mais il se passe quoi elle est en
train de faire quoi là et là après la
machine elle se met en route c'était la
dernière chose à laquelle je m'attendais
dans
une SA sœur Laetitia ma sœur était en
face de moi tout en larmes
oui tu me payeras pour ce que tu as fait
j'ai fait mais je t'ai fait quoi j'ai
fait il faut m'expliquer parce que là je
comprends rien du tout elle fait oui tu
me tenais quand Patrick
il me forcer toi tu me tenais j'ai
fait huit de quoi et j'ai fait je
comprenais plus rien vous êtes si vous
êtes assis dans un bureau vous êtes
menotté vous êtes face à un officier de
police qui vous pose des questions
comment ça s'est passé pourquoi vous
avez fait ça et vous vous donnez les
réponses mais les réponses ne
conviennent pas à tout moment tout ce
qu'on disait c'était pas vrai
il n'avait Dieu que pour ce qu'avait dit
ma belle-sœur Laetitia c'était elle elle
nous on était vraiment comme des
pestiférés on avait violé la garde à vue
est tendue Michel qui est enceinte de 8
mois est très affaibli et ressent des
contractions elle est conduite à
l'hôpital Nord de Marseille
il y a un médecin qui me reçoit en
présence des policiers
le médecin était vraiment furieux parce
que il a demandé aux policiers de Me
démenotter parce que c'était pas un lieu
où on attache des femmes
les policiers ils ont dit écoutez nous
on est obligé aller en garde à vue cette
personne là donc on est obligé bon ils
m'ont menotté sur ce ils ont pas voulu
me défaire
comment on peut salir les gens comme ça
Patrick lui est toujours questionné il
est épuisé à bout de force après 48
heures de garde à vue il est interrogé
par un nouvel officier qui selon lui
n'aurait pas hésité à l'intimider pour
lui extorquer des aveux on va parler
entre hommes
à l'époque des faits dont tu es accusé
tu étais mineur tu passeras en tribunal
correctionnel tu risques pas grand chose
mais il faut que tu nous dises ce qui
s'est passé ce que tu as fait je sais
mais j'ai rien fait cette première
tentative est entam
ée encore plus dur
elle dit tu sais regarde là ta femme
elle est enceinte de 8 mois passé
tu as deux enfants tes deux enfants
ce qui va se passer si tu continuais à
nier comme ça tes deux enfants ils vont
aller à la DASS ta femme elle va être
incarcéré
elle va accoucher en prison elle va
garder l'enfant un an et de là on le
mettra à la DASS aussi je peux vous
assurer quand il m'a dit ça dans ma tête
ça fait femme en fond prison das c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible c'est je
peux pas je peux pas leur faire ça donc
à ce moment là j'ai dit oui je l'ai fait
j'ai eu peur donc pour les protéger j'ai
préféré assumer et avouer quelque chose
que je n'avais pas fait
est-ce que ça existe encore ça
aujourd'hui est-ce que la présence de
l'avocat maintenant on garde à vue évite
ce genre de problème le fait que
l'avocat puisse être présent dès la
première heure de garde à vue c'est un
progrès on se caisse ça ne permet plus
les pressions théoriquement mais faut-il
encore que la personne vous appelle on
est confronté très souvent à des
personnes qui sortent de garde à vue qui
viennent voir leur avocat ou un avocat
s'il en avait pas avant et qui vous
disent ben oui je suis resté seul à la
garde à vue et ça s'est mal passé quand
on leur dit pourquoi vous avez pas plein
d'avocat on m'a répondu ça ne sert à
rien d'ailleurs les innocents n'ont pas
besoin d'avocat et le juge il voit que
tu as pris un avocat il dira c'est
d'être le gars il a déjà quelque chose à
se reprocher donc la présence d'avocat
en garde à vue c'est un immense progrès
démocratique faut-il encore que la
personne place en garde à vue on l'est
bien notifié ses droits ça c'est quand
même généralement le cas maintenant ça
s'améliorer globalement mais faut-il
encore qu'elle ne renonce pas à ses
droits à voir un avocat et l'avoir avec
lui et vous savez il y a une phrase qui
est de Démosthène qui dit la véritable
bonne question ce n'est pas de savoir
combien vous coûtera votre défense mais
combien il vous en coûtera de ne pas
vous êtes défendu ça ça reste
d'actualité 2000 ans 2500 ans plus tard
après une garde à vue musclée Patrick
Leveneur a avoué un viol qu'il n'a pas
commis le lendemain il est déféré au
palais de justice de Marseille devant
une juge d'instruction innocent l'homme
s'apprête pourtant à dormir en prison
[Musique]
quelques semaines après sa tentative de
suicide Christophe Bridoux et lui aussi
convoqué au commissariat il pense qu'il
va enfin pouvoir s'expliquer et qu'on
reconnaîtra son innocence au contraire
le policier municipal est placé en garde
à vue la garde élu c'est très mal passé
on est resté je suis resté
dans tout ce temps interroger sans
savoir quelle heure il était désorienté
sur le plan de la nuit du jour plus de
repères absolument rien vole escroquerie
Christophe est interrogé au sujet des
multiples fées qu'on lui reproche mais
pas seulement le policier va bientôt
l'accuser de fait bien plus grave et on
me place une image à caractère
P2 pornographique sous les yeux en me
demandant tout simplement d'où venait
cette image
et on me déclare voilà mais d'une
simplicité que ça sortait de mon
ordinateur que ça m’était retrouvé par
mon ex adjoint
tout un abri de comme ça de choses qui
ne tiennent même pas la route et
d'ailleurs je fais pas au fonctionnaire
de police que leur affaire ne tiennent
pas que ce n'est pas possible c'est
incohérent c'est totalement incohérent
les accusations portées à l'encontre de
Christophe Bridoux sont très lourdes il
se souvient alors de la question de la
mère de Garges-lès-Gonesse sur son
homosexualité pour lui il y a un grave
amalgame cette corrélation justement qui
est faite entre l'homosexualité et la
pédophilie je crois que là elle est
totalement révélatrice et que on peut
pas mettre de côté le fait qu'il y ait
un acte d'homophobie Christophe Bridoux
a beau clamé son innocence tout au long
de la garde à vue les policiers ne le
croient pas
il arrive un moment aujourd'hui je leur
ai dit d'ailleurs je leur ai dit mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez sur votre
procédure je sais que je suis innocent
face aux accusations qui ont été portées
à mon encontre j'ai jamais pu je n'ai
jamais pu j'avais l'impression de
d'avoir devant moi une porte close
personne ne m'écoutait Christophe est
ensuite présenté au juge d'instruction
au palais de justice de Pontoise le
magistrat le met en examen accusation la
plus grave recèle d'images
pédopornographiques et il me demande
tout simplement avez-vous quelque chose
à déclarer oui monsieur le juge je suis
innocent je suis innocent
et il me répond spontanément tous ceux
qui passent ici sont innocents
Christophe ressort libre de son audition
mais il est placé sous contrôle
judiciaire plus dur encore étant
poursuivi pour Russell d'images
pédopornographiques Christophe n'a plus
le droit de voir son fils une nouvelle
difficile à annoncer à son ex-femme
je lui annonçais tout simplement que je
n'ai plus le droit de voir victorien
à la demande du juge donc je suis écarté
de mes enfants
je n'ai plus de travail on m'a révoqué
donc qui travaille plus d'argent donc je
me retrouve sans rien
on commence à saisir mes biens je peux
payer je n'ai plus rien de galère
professionnelle en dépression Christophe
Bridoux devient SDF il échoue sur les
quais de Seine face à l'île de la Cité
là on est sur mon ancienne
lieu de résidence
voilà
j'ai je suis resté quasiment pendant
presque deux ans
c'est mon petit appart mon petit lit
ça c'est bon
là j'avais la poubelle qui permettait de
me servir éventuellement dans les
c'est une sensation étrange
[Musique]
c'est
là d'un seul coup tout me revient en
plein visage c'est dur quoi
c'est très dur je crois que ce qui m'a
le plus marqué c'est pas le fait de
chercher à manger c'est surtout
de s'apercevoir que on est au même titre
que les rats on a les on est recouverts
de carton parce que il faut se protéger
quand même même la nuit même s'il fait
bon on entend de ce
on s'aperçoit qu'on a deux trois rats au
pied qui sont en train de ranger le
carton Christophe dort dans la rue de
2003 2005 une période pendant laquelle
il se sent abandonné par la justice car
l'enquête n'avance pas pendant ce temps
impossible pour lui d'être lavé des
accusations de pédophilie
parmi les multiples cas recensés
d'accusation à tort la pédophilie reste
quand même très récurrente de
l'accusation je dirais le plus facile
pour nuire à quelqu'un c'est quand même
d'inventer des affaires de mœurs
s'imaginaires et notamment sur des
enfants et si possible entre bas comme
ça naturellement les éléments de preuve
qui peuvent être apportées à charger à
des charges sont beaucoup plus complexes
à rapporter donc ça reste ce qui a la
fois le plus infamant le plus
destructeur ou les dommages collatéraux
directs éclatéraux sont les plus
importants et où il sera également le
plus difficile de s'en débarrasser pour
la personne qui est innocente parce que
très souvent enfin la plupart du temps
dans les affaires vraiment de pédophiles
où ils en font sont très bas âge la
parole de l'enfant est en elle-même
assez peu audible mais recueilli par des
tiers et c'est par l'interprétation des
tiers personne médicale personnel
scolaire famille bon que l'on arrive à
faire une construction souvent
artificielle de culpabilité est-ce qu'il
y a eu des progrès là à ce niveau là
justement sur le recueil de la parole
des enfants je serai tenté de dire qu'il
y a quand même
notamment depuis l'affaire tragique
d'Outreau une plus grande prudence
notamment dans les milieux sociaux dans
les milieux scolaires dans les milieux
judiciaires les mieux médicaux ont
toujours été relativement prudent mais
dans les milieux on va dire
parascolaires parascolaire paramédicaux
sociaux et judiciaire il y a quand même
une plus grande prudence et une moins
grande sacralisation de la parole de
l'enfant la parole de l'enfant n'est
plus parole d'évangile comme elle
pouvait l'être notamment avant ou trop
seul sans emploi sans logement accusé de
fait très grave Christophe Bridoux est
un homme brisé pourtant à la fin de
l'année 2005 l'ancien policier municipal
va pouvoir commencer à remonter la pente
[Musique]
13 mars 1997 tandis que Michel sa femme
est retournée seule à Paris Patrick
Leveneur est conduit en fourgon
cellulaire à la prison de Marseille
direction les Baumettes nous allons la
prison des Baumettes dès son arrivée au
Baumettes Patrick est incarcéré dans le
quartier le plus difficile de la prison
j'ai été installé au deuxième Nord
le deuxième Nord c'est le quartier
résidentiel des pointeurs entre
guillemets des violeurs le violeur c'est
un pestiféré en prison Patrick
partage avec un autre détenu sa vie en
prison est rythmée par les promenades
une heure par jour mais aussi par les
parties de cartes et les parloirs le
moment le plus dur que j'ai eu là-bas
c'est quand j'ai eu mon premier parloir
avec ma mère qui est venue et qui m'a
amené mon fils Ludovic
il avait 6 ans à l'époque là c'était
super dur ce que ça faisait plus de deux
mois que je crois que j'avais pas vu mon
fils que j'avais plus de contact quoi
c'était que de l'écrit et
quand on m'a dit que j'avais parloir
j'étais surpris déjà et quand je suis
arrivé là-bas que j'ai vu mon bébé de 6
ans et ma mère vous imaginez j'ai pleuré
et quand je suis remonté de ce de ce
soir
j'étais pas bien j'étais vraiment pas
bien pendant sa détention
clamer son innocence
sans résultat
on fait des demandes de liberté qui
reviennent tout le temps rejeter demande
rejetée
des demandes de remise en liberté
en prison Patrick n'a pas le droit de
voir Michel sa femme car elle est mise
en examen pour complicité de viol du
coup presque chaque jour il lui écrit
tu mets le plus en rogne dans tout ça
c'est d'être mélangé à tous ces
pédophiles alors quand les autres
prisonniers nous voient descendre en
promenade je te dis pas le genre
d'insultes qui se disent mais moi je
m'en fous je me sens pas visé car je
suis innocent je suis fier de ce que je
suis un homme qui n'a jamais violé qui
que ce soit et je vais me battre
jusqu'au bout pour que mon innocence
soit prouvé c'est important et se
soutenir quoi
S
c'est ce que j'attendais tous les jours
il fallait que tous les jours
j'attendais du courrier
[Musique]
Patrick apprend la naissance de son
troisième fils
mon cher papa chéri c'est moi Patrick
ton fils chéri comme promis je t'envoie
l'écriture de maman tout mon bonheur je
suis née le ciné 97
aujourd'hui Patrick a 15 ans ses parents
lui ont souvent raconté pour quelle
raison il portait le même prénom que son
père
de Patrick parce que moment de la
naissance il y avait pas mon père mon
père était encore en prison
maintenant je représente un peu mon père
voilà je suis fier
je suis très très fier
pendant son incarcération Patrick reçoit
peu de visite heureusement il peut
compter sur une amie de sa mère
[Musique]
Monique habite les quartiers nord de
Marseille pendant la détention de
Patrick chaque semaine elle traverse la
ville pour lui apporter du linge propre
et prendre de ses nouvelles
je l'ai dit parce que une déjà une je
sais que Patrick il a pas fait ses
conneries Patrick
avec sa femme son trop proche non pas du
tout et de sa mère sa mère j'ai la
considère comme une sœur jusqu'à
maintenant
et
en trois j'ai moi aussi j'ai des enfants
[Musique]
comment aller mon épouse comment aller
ma mère comment les mes enfants
aiment me donner de la force à
m'encourager ça aussi vachement aidé mon
épouse parce que elle avait des
nouvelles par l'intermédiaire de Monique
aussi
elle savait comment j'allais Monique lui
disait si j'avais un peu maigri si
j'avais le moral donc en fin de compte
elle était
elle faisait l'intermédiaire quoi
vous êtes psychanalyste même en étant
innocent éprouvons une forme de
culpabilité lorsqu'on est accusé à tort
mais c'est tout le problème et je crois
que pour le comprendre il faut vraiment
quitter le terrain de la réalité pour ce
que nous appelons dans notre jargon
l'imaginaire c'est-à-dire en gros ce qui
va se passer à partir d'une réalité
donnée dans la tête de quelqu'un bon
quelqu'un est accusateur il sait bien
que il a pas fait ce qu'on l'accuse
d'avoir fait mais il y a plusieurs
raisons qui font que cette certitude va
vaciller jusqu'à même disparaître la
première c'est que il se retrouve en
face d'une force qui est réellement une
force comme par exemple en garde à vue
il y a quelque chose qui se passe dans
l'imaginaire c'est que la personne qui
est accusée et renvoyée au fond à une
position d'enfant elle est renvoyée à
cette position d'enfant du fait de son
impuissance il y a un décalage de force
énorme et elle se retrouve comme
l'enfant accusé devant l'adulcorant un
adulte accuse un enfant à tort il vient
jouer sur la culpabilité de l'enfant qui
n'a peut-être pas fait ce qu'on lui
reproche mais qu'a fait d'autres choses
dont ils s'en coupables donc si vous
voulez ce qui se passe dans une
situation réelle de l'âge adulte c'est
qu'on est toujours inconsciemment
renvoyé à ce qu'on a vécu avant et il
peut y avoir dans ce qu'on a vécu avant
quelque chose qui vient majorer la
violence incroyable qu'il y a toujours
dans la réalité quel que soit l'histoire
qu'on ait eu à être accusé à tort
[Musique]
après plus de trois mois de détention à
la prison des Baumettes à Marseille
Patrick Leveneur clame toujours son
innocence mais personne ne semble
l'entendre pourtant son affaire va
bientôt connaître un rebondissement
inespéré
[Musique]
depuis deux ans Christophe Bridou dort
dans les rues de Paris mais en 2005 un
ami lui permet de retrouver un emploi et
un logement il devient gardien de cet
immeuble près de la place de la
République
et d'ailleurs j'avoue des appartements
donc j'avais la cuisine j'avais une
espèce de cuisine
j'avais mon salon qui faisait aussi ses
chambres à coucher parce que je crois
que j'avais tellement peur de perdre mon
toit de me retrouver dans la rue
j'avais cette notion de vouloir
conserver mon bien et je me suis donné
corps et à me dans mon travail je
faisais même plus que je ne devais faire
parce que je voulais montrer que j'étais
capable de quelque chose et je voulais
rendre service
aux résidents de d'ici vous allez bien
ça a grandi hein
cela fait deux ans que Christophe n'a
pas vu ses résidents
c'est ici que Christophe a appris la
nouvelle qui lui a permis de se relever
c'était en février 2007
je me souviens encore j'étais en train
de cirer les escaliers et mon téléphone
portable sonne et je vois le nom de mon
avocat qui apparaît
et je me dis s'il m'appelle c'est qu'il
y a toujours rien de bon
et il me dit ça y est nous y sommes nous
avons un quadruple non lieu
et je me suis mis à pleurer mais sans
pouvoir me contrôler je pense que l'aîné
était tellement
à rue des preuves que je
faisais maintenant plus de 7 ans que
j'attendais quand même plus de 7 ans
sans éléments à charge Christophe
Bridoux est désormais lavé de tout
soupçons sur l'ensemble des chefs
d'accusation sa priorité revoir son fils
victorien
j'ai demandé à mon ex-femme de voir le
dernier que j'avais je n'avais pas vu
depuis 7 ans qui avait 9 mois au moment
où je suis parti
je lui demande de le revoir et ça a été
un long cheminement parce qu'on voulait
pas le traumatiser
aujourd'hui Christoph
e et
qui a choisi
j'ai raté tout simplement le fait de ses
premiers papas ses premiers pas c'est
le fait de gambader partout le fait tout
ça voilà les premiers gagas les points
de gueule et pour les papas ça c'est des
antennes
[Musique]
après ça séparation avec Christophe il y
a 11 ans Véronique assombri dans
l'alcool et la dépression
mais depuis qu'il a été innocenté ils se
sont de nouveau rapprochés à présent
tous deux se soutiennent comme ça se
passe très bien avec son fils et qui
s'en occupe très bien
j'ai je vois pas pourquoi je serai
contre lui je dirais il faut aussi jouer
la carte de l'intelligence et moi pour
mon fils pour mon fils est important
qu'il y a un équilibre et le fait qu'il
est avec son père ça se passe très bien
et ben voilà ça se passe très bien avec
moi aussi
Claude dalmos la solitude des personnes
accusatoires est très forte
l'entourage joue un rôle primordial non
l'entourage mais quand même il faut que
ce soit un entourage alors bien sûr il
faut il faut écouter les gens il faut
les accompagner il faut il faut être
présent physiquement parce que ce sont
des gens qui sont atteints psychiquement
mais qui sont atteints dans leur corps
enfin c'est quelque chose qui fait
exploser même le corps on part en
miettes enfin quand on est comme ça
dénié dans sa vérité dans ses valeurs
bon mais il faut quand même qu'il y ait
moi je crois beaucoup enfin quand je
reçois des passions qui sont dans cet
état là il faut vraiment des avocats
costauds il faut pas il faut pas rêver
c'est pas juste les gentils camarades de
votre gentil épouse votre gentille Marie
qui va vous aider il faut absolument
garantir à la personne que la loi existe
là tout d'un coup cette personne se
retrouve au fond dans un monde sans loi
n'importe qui peut vous dire n'importe
quoi de vous n'importe qui peut vous
accuser à tort et personne ne va vous
croire donc il faut que la personne pour
avoir un point d'appui sans que c'est
pas vrai il y a une loi et il y a des
gens qui sont capables de mettre en
marche cette loi et ça à part à part les
avocats à part les associations la
défense etc bah il y a personne d'autre
ça suffit pas à l'entourage est-ce que
le taux de subsiste dans l'entourage
parfois bien sûr
il y a cette idée quand même que la
justice bon elle peut se tromper mais
elle peut pas se il y a pas de fumée
sans feu hein comme dit la sagesse
populaire vous pensez bien quand même
hein que si on l'a accusé comme ça cet
homme là c'est que peut-être quand même
qu'il y a quelque chose et alors après
ça sonne c'est à dire que d'ailleurs on
avait bien remarqué que peut-être il y
avait bon c'est toutes ces espèces de de
choses redoutables et encore une fois
faut jamais oublier que ça peut mener
quelqu'un à la mort c'est à dire que
dans ces cas-là le suicide il faut le
savoir c'est pas c'est pas bien sûr on
se tue pour que ça s'arrête parce que
c'est atroce mais on se tue surtout pour
tuer celui qu'on croit être devenu celui
qui pourra plus jamais faire entendre
qu'il est pas ce qu'on dit qu'il est
voilà on tue celui-là et malheureusement
on se tue
après quatre mois de détention Patrick
Leveneur apprend une nouvelle inattendue
sa belle-sœur Laetitia qui l'accuse de
l'avoir violé ce serait trahi ma
belle-sœur a été convoquée chez le juge
et a voulu en remettre une une autre
couche pour m'accablir encore plus elle
s'est présenté ses juges avec un œil au
beurre noir
et elle a elle a dit au juge voilà c'est
mon beau-frère il est revenu pour tenter
de m'agresser
et la juge lui dit mais attendez on va
arrêter deux secondes votre beau-frère
ça va faire 4 mois qu'il est derrière
les barreaux comment il peut sortir des
Baumettes venir vous agresser entre
guillemets et retourner dans sa cellule
donc maintenant il faut venir la vérité
et c'est vrai qu'ils ont vu qu'elle
était tendance à la fabulation le juge a
cassé petit à petit tout ce qu'elle
argumentait au fil des auditions et des
expertises psychologiques de la
belle-sœur la juge se rend compte que
Patrick est innocent elle décide
immédiatement de le faire libérer
parce qu'on a beau dire on respire à
l'intérieur mais on respire mieux de ce
côté là quand même et je sors avec un
sac plastique avec le peu d'habit que
j'avais et voilà la porte elle s'ouvre
pareil elle se referme et là vous êtes
dehors vous faites waouh j'ai vu le café
qui est en face le café s'appelle ici
mieux qu'en face je suis allé boire un
café tout de suite à l'autre bout de la
France Michel apprend la libération de
Patrick quelques heures seulement avant
sa sortie des Baumettes cela fait quatre
mois qu'elle ne l'a pas vu
le 20 juin je ressens un coup de
téléphone c'est mon avocate
elle me dit oui bonjour madame Leveneur
voilà votre mari libérable
j'avais un mal dans la main je suis
tombé à genoux sec
j'y croyais pas
un an après les leveneurs bénéficient
d'un non-lieu
leur accusatrice est condamnée à 6 mois
de prison avec sursis et une obligation
de soins psychiatriques pour
dénonciation calomnieuse Patrick et
Michel pensent qu'ils vont enfin pouvoir
tourner la page mais l'affaire n'est pas
encore terminée
[Musique]
même innocenté la descente aux enfers de
Christophe Bridoux a laissé des traces
sur sa santé psychologique
bipolaire il doit suivre un lourd
traitement médical
[Musique]
ça c'est dans un c'est mon sac qui me
permet de vivre avec tous les
médicaments
et ça c'est un somnifère puissant depuis
maintenant parce que 10 ans ma vie c'est
n'est composé que de médicaments je
souffre d'un syndrome extrêmement
important
parce que tout simplement voilà des gens
m'ont accusés voilà c'est une thérapie
que j'aurais avis à
marquer à vie Christophe ne veut pas en
rester là il a déposé plein de pour
dénonciation calomnieuse contre son ex
employeur à la mairie de
Garges-lès-Gonesse
ce matin il a rendez-vous avec son
avocat chez une juge d'instruction au
palais de justice de Pontoise c'est la
première fois depuis 10 ans
ça fait maintenant quelques années que
j'attends ce moment
je sais pas un peu perturbé un peu un
peu flou un peu le vagues je sais pas
trop la juge d'instruction a des
questions nous avons des questions mais
nous avons aussi beaucoup de réponses
qui doivent conduire à ce que les
auteurs des plaintes injustifiées contre
Monsieur Bridoux soit mis en examen et
un jour renvoyé devant un tribunal
pendant les deux heures d'audition dans
le bureau de la juge Christophe Bridoux
est revenu sur cette journée du 11
septembre 2001 il a exposé sa version
des faits
à la sortie du palais il semble
satisfait
c'est très positif c'est très positif et
j'espère que ça soit encore davantage
lorsque je reviendrai et que j'aurai des
éléments nouveaux mais pour moi c'était
une grande avancée rencontrée durant un
peu plus de deux heures un magistrat
c'est une très très bien avancé
aujourd'hui on ne discute plus de
l'innocence de Christophe Bridoux
aujourd'hui on veut comprendre on
cherche à comprendre pourquoi est-ce que
le chef de la police municipale de la
ville de Garges-lès-Gonesse avec un état
de service exemplaire a été jeté en
pâture a été destitué révoquer place en
garde à vue privé du droit de voir ses
enfants devenus SDF par le jeu d'une
accusation multiple
ignoble aujourd'hui Christophe Bridoux
veut comprendre il espère une
confrontation avec la mère de
Garges-lès-Gonesse de l'époque le but
obtenir des réponses à ces questions
[Musique]
après la sortie de prison de Patrick les
leveneurs tentent d'oublier les
accusations à tort de la sœur de Michel
cette dernière a d'ailleurs rompu tout
lien avec sa famille qui ne l'a pas
soutenu dans cette histoire
là des restants de photos on va dire
c'était le genre de mon mariage
et j'ai retiré toutes sortes toutes les
photos où il y avait ma sœur avec son
mari je pouvais plus voir ces photos
avec ces deux personnes là qui nous ont
fait un tas d'histoire quoi
malgré tout pour Michel et Patrick en
dépit de la condamnation de la
belle-sœur en 2001 difficile de tourner
la page car jusqu'en 2004 soit 7 ans
après le début de l'affaire ils sont
toujours obligés de pointer chaque mois
à la gendarmerie
97 du 11 mars 97
afin
ma vie ne m'appartenait pas
elle appartenait à la justice j'étais
obligé de rendre des comptes pendant
tout ce temps là et maintenant il est
logique que je demande à la justice de
m'en rendre
Patrick et Michel ont décidé d'attaquer
les deux policiers qui auraient extorqué
des aveux la procédure est rarissime
ils ont fait appel au très médiatique
Gilbert Collard
important que le fonctionnaire de police
soit reconnu personnellement responsable
d'une faute
à l'heure mieux que n'importe quoi je
trouve on a l'honneur d'être policier
on fait pas pression sur
un gardien à vue pour lui faire avouer
des actes qui n'a pas commis voilà c'est
c'est un procès pour l'honneur beaucoup
plus que pour l'argent
vous avez été gendarmes pendant 32 ans
on entend régulièrement le témoignage de
personnes accusées à tort est-ce que
vous vous aviez cette crainte de faire
condamner un innocent bien sûr
au cours des nombreuses années pendant
lesquelles j'ai mené des enquêtes
criminelles chaque fois que nous avions
interpellé quelqu'un supposé être le
criminel il y avait toujours ce doute
qui subsistait de ne pas envoyer
quelqu'un en prison alors qu'il était
pour rien vaut mieux laisser en liberté
un criminelle c'est ce qu'on dit parfois
plutôt d'envoyer un innocent en prison
et c'est donc effectivement présent à
chaque à chaque instant quoi c'est la
raison pour laquelle à chaque fois que
nous intervenions il y avait des un plan
bien précis de travail pour poser des
questions etc et surtout faire en sorte
que la la personne interpellée ne nous
fasse pas plaisir en répondant par
l'affirmative aux questions qu'on
pouvait lui poser on peut imaginer que
tous les gendarmes tous les policiers
[Musique]
les deux policiers qui auraient sans le
moindre état d'âme extorquer ses aveux à
Patrick Leveneur devrait être jugés dans
les mois qui viennent ensuite seulement
cette histoire pourra être
définitivement reléguée au passé
être accusé à tort un drame humain une
violation de la présomption d'innocence
qui chaque année brise des milliers
d'existence
si Christophe Bridoux pense que sa
cicatrice ne se refermera pas je crois
que ma vie brisait à jamais
jusque jusqu'à mon dernier souffle je ne
pourrais pas un jour où je n'y pense pas
pas un jour
Patrick lui a choisi de pardonner son
accusatrice pour mieux tourner la page
je suis pas rancunier vous savez que
j'ai pas de haine envers
j'ai de la pitié de l'incompréhension